[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم في المقابله من
الحبشه البلاد التي هاجر اليها المسلمون
الاوائل خوفا على دينهم اثيوبيا العاصمه
السياسيه للاتحاد الافريقي التقي رئيس
الوزراء هنا هايلي مريم ديسالين واتحدث
معه في شؤون عده الاحتجاجات والاضطرابات
التي شهدتها البلاد منذ اشهر العلاقات
المضطربه والمعقده ايضا مع اريتريا
العلاقات المعقده جدا مع مصر واشكاليه سد
النهضه ونهر النيل وكذلك كل الامور
المتعلقه بالقرن الافريقي والعلاقات
العربيه الاثيوبيه الحاليه
والمرتقب ولد رئيس الوزراء الاثيوبي هايلي
مريم ديسالين في جنوب اثيوبيا عام 2009
965 درس في جامعه اديس ابابا وحصل على
شهاده الماجستير في الهندسه الصحيه في
فنلندا عام
1991 بعد عودته في العام ذاته اطاحت
الجبهه الشعبيه الثوريه الديمقراطيه في
اثيوبيا بنظام
منجستو وفي اواخر التسعينيات نشط هيل مريم
في حزب الجبهه الشعبيه الذي يحكم البلاد
وفي عام 2000 عين نائبا لرئيس اقليم الامم
الجنوبيه في اثيوبيا ولاحقا تراس هذا
الاقليم حتى عام
2005 في العام التالي عرف هيلي مريم محليا
بعد ان اتخذه رئيس الوزراء السابق ملس
زيناوي مستشارا له في الشؤون الاجتماعيه
وفي عام
2008 اصبح المنسق العامه في الحكومه في
عام 2010 اصبح هيلي مريم نائبا لرئيس
الوزراء في حكومه زيناوي كما شغل ايضا
منصب وزير الخارجيه وبعد وفاه رئيس
الوزراء ملا الزيناوي عام 2012 اصبح هيلي
مريم رئيس الوزراء في البلاد باعتباره اول
رئيس بروتستانتي قادم من جنوب البلاد ولا
ينتمي الى عرقيت الامهر
وتجره منذ العقد الماضي تمتعت اثيوبيا
بواحد من اعلى معدلات النمو الاقتصادي في
افريقيا وبرز دورها لاعبا رئيسيا في
منظومه دول الاتحاد الافريقي
ومكونا رئيسيا في قوات حفظ السلام
الافريقيه نشط هيلي مريم في قضيه السلام
بين السودان وجنوب السودان وفي عام
2013 زار البلدين محاولا تنسيق التفاهم
بين
الحكومتين تصر حكومه هيلي مريم على اكمال
مشروع سد النهضه الذي ادخل البلاد في خلاف
مع مصر بسبب ما تقول مصر انه تهديد لامنها
المائي فاز هيل مريم مره اخرى في انتخاب
بلاده عام
2015 وهو العام ذاته الذي اتسعت فيه
المظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ضد الحكومه ولا تزال
هذه المظاهرات في تجدد خصوصا في المناطق
الحدوديه التي تتجاور فيها العرقيات
فيدراليا وقد ظل رد الحكومه العنيف الذي
اودى بحياه مئات المتظاهرين يطرح تساؤلات
عن ديمقراطيه البلاد ومدى احترامها لحقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في هذا اللقاء
من هنا من ادي سبابا عاصمه اثيوبيا اللقاء
الذي يجمعنا برئيس الوزراء السيد هايلي
مريم دي سال مرحبا بك سيد دي سالن سعداء
بوجودك في المقابله
وحينما وصلت هنا البارحه الى اثيوبيا شعرت
بشيء بلمسه خاصه حقيقه لم اشعر بغربه
كبيره شعرت ان ثمت مشترك بين العرب
والحبشه تاريخ طويل ماذا تشعرون تجاه
العرب او تجاه علاقتكم مع
العرب بدايه اشكركم على الاستضافه في هذا
البرنامج ان هذه الارض شكلت مهد الانسانيه
فجميع اجدادكم قد خرجوا من هذا البلد كما
ان هناك تقاربا كبيرا بيننا وبين البلدان
والشعوب العربيه فهناك الكثير من الامور
المشتركه بيننا كما شهدت بلادنا زيارات
لزعماء وقاده من البلدان العربيه منذ مطلع
التاريخ وهناك ايضا علاقات راسخه تربطنا
بالعرب منذ عهد النبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم عندما امر اصحابه بالهجره الى
الحبشه وهناك مكان تاريخي هنا يعرف باسم
النجاشي فعلاقتنا اذا بالعرب لها ابعا
دينيه وانسانيه متجذر
وبالتالي من الطبيعي ان ينتابك هذا الشعور
لان ثمه ثقافه وهويه وعلاقات مشتركه فيما
بيننا وكلما تاتي الى اثيوبيا ينتابك نفس
الشعور ولا اعتقد ان هذا يحدث
مصادفه بل ان وراءه اسبابا تاريخيه
وطيده هل تعتقد ان العرب اليوم
واثيوبيا يعني لديهما علاقه تليق بهذه
الجيره وهذا التاريخ
الطويل العلاقه بين الجانبين قويه جدا
واظن ان العلاقه بين قاده اثيوبيا والقاده
العرب لم تكن بنفس قوه علاقه الشعوب
ببعضها البعض لذا علينا ان على تقويه هذه
العلاقات وتعزيزها لان ثمه امورا تربطنا
ببعضنا البعض كما ان اسباب وجودنا متشابهه
بقدر كبير لذا علينا العمل على تعميق هذه
العلاقات فيما بيننا لا سيما على المستوى
الديني والثقافي والتقارب الانساني وطريقه
تفكيرنا ونظرتنا الى العالم وهذه كلها
امور مشتركه بين الاثيوبيين والشعوب
العربيه
ومن هنا فان من
مسؤوليتنا ان نعمل على تعزيز العلاقات
القائمه على سبيل المثال هناك زياده هائله
في اعداد العرب الذين ياتون لزياره
اثيوبيا لكننا لازلنا بحاجه الى المزيد من
التسهيلات لتعزيز الروابط بين الشعوب
وهناك حاجه ايضا لجذب مزيد من الاستثمارات
من دول الخليج فهناك فرص للاستثمار هنا في
اثيوبيا متمثله في وجود الاراضي الشاسعه
والموارد البشريه والمناخ الرائع والبلدان
العربيه لا سيما دول الخليج لديها ثروات
وموارد ينبغي الاستثمار فيها لذا فاننا
اذا تعاونا فسيمكنك ان نحول منطقتي الخليج
والقرن الافريقي الى اماكن افضل لشعوبنا
اود ان اتحدث عنكم سيد رئيس الوزراء عنك
شخصيا توليت رئاسه الوزراء فتره من اعوام
كنت خليفه لميل الزيناوي رئيس الوزراء
الشهير في في اثيوبيا وفي افريقيا طبعا
كان هناك حديث انه قد لا تكون مدتك اطول
لكن يبدو انك اليوم انت طبعا انتخبت يضا
دوره
جديده واتيت ربما من خارج الدائره
التقليديه اسالك عم مل الزيناوي ماذا يمثل
لك رئيس الوزراء
الراحل
ستيت برايم منستر رئيس الوزراء الراحل ميل
الزيناوي
كان رجل دوله فوق العاده كان صاحب شخصيه
فريده ومواهب فذه سواء اكان في اداره
البلاد ام العلوم ام الاقتصاد لذا اعتبر
نفسي محظوظا على المستوى الشخصي ان اتيحت
لي فرصه العمل معه اثناء فتره قيادته
للبلاد ولقد قمنا في الحزب وفي الحكومه
بوضع سياسات معه وتحت
اشرافه لذا فاننا سير على نفس المنهج الذي
رسمه لنا والمسؤوليه الملقاه على عاتقي هي
احداث تغيير في البلاد واستكمال مسيره
الاصلاح التي بدات بالفعل وكل ثقه باننا
نسير في المسار الصحيح لتحقيق ذلك وقد
تمكنت خلال السنوات الاربع الماضيه من وضع
البلاد على طريق الازدهار
تعلم اننا قد تمكنا من تحقيق الرقم
المزدوج في النمو الاقتصادي على مدار ال
سنه الماضيه فيما يمكن ان نعتبره معجزه
واستطعنا ايضا القضاء على الفقر في البلاد
وتقليص معدلات السكان الذين يعيشون تحت خط
الفقر بنسبه 50% ولا يزال امامنا الكثير
من الجهود للقضاء على الفقر في البلاد
وبالتالي فان مهمتي في هذا السياق هي
العمل على توحيد جميع فئات الشعب لتحقيق
التغيير المنشود في البلاد ولا اخفيك انني
اشعر بسعاده خلال عملي على تحقيق الاهداف
التي وضعناها سويا مع رئيس الوزراء الراحل
السيد زيناوي واشعر بالرضا على ذلك تتحدث
مؤسسات الحقوق الانسان الغربيه بشكل عام
هيوم رايتس وش عن مساله حقوق الانسان
تثيرها بشكل دائم في في اثيوبيا وهناك
حديث ايضا عن الديمقراطيه هنا في هذا
البلد الان حاله الطوارئ معلنه منذ الشهر
الماضي هناك احتجاجات في اجزاء من البلد
كيف ترى هذه المساله هل لديكم تقصير في
مسائل تتعلق بحقوق الانسان هل ثم انتهاكات
في هذا
الجانب
ست لنتحدث اولا عن الديمقراطيه وحقوق
الانسان في اثيوبيا ان الامر ليس مجرد
ممارسات تكميليه او ثانويه نقوم بها بل
انها مساله مصيريه بالنسبه لنا بمعنى اننا
اذا لم نحقق الديمقراطيه ونحترم حقوق
الانسان في البلاد فسوف ينتهي الامر بنا
حتما الى مشهد من التفكك والفوضى ومن هنا
فاننا نؤمن بان الديمقراطيه مساله مصيريه
ببساطه لاننا نتحمل مسؤوليه تجاه شعبنا
وهي تامين الحق المشروع في الحوار
الديمقراطي لجميع فصائل الشعب الاثيوبي
ولا نفعل ذلك بموجب املاءات تاتينا من
الخارج هيوم الرايت وش او
غيرها ولكن لان علينا مسؤوليه والتزاما
بالعمل وفقا لاحكام الدستور الاثيوبي الذي
يعد واحدا من افضل الدساتير العالميه
واحدثها علينا احترام احكام الدستور
وعلينا تنفيذها وهذا هو السبيل الوحيد
للمضي قدما بالبلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
ودائما اثناء التحول من حقبه الحكومه
القمعيه التي حكمت على مدار العش سنه
الماضيه الى الديمقراطيه سنمر بنجاحات
واخفاقات
ونتعلم من خلال الممارسه لذا فانني ارى ان
هذه الديمقراطيه الانتقاليه لا تزال نشئه
الناس يتحدثون عن الديمقراطيه فحتى
البلدان التي ترسخت لديها ثقافه
الديمقراطيه على مدار م عام ترى ان
ديمقراطيتها لا تزال منقوصه الديمقراطيه
عندنا لم تتجاوز 20 عاما لم تجرى
الانتخابات عندنا الا اربع مرات لك ان
تتخيل هذه ديمقراطيه وليده تحتاج الى وقت
كي تنضج ان تحقيق الديمقراطيه يتم من خلال
تغيير ثقافه
الشعوب وهذه ليست بالمهمه اليسيره التي
يمكن ان تتحقق بين عشيه وضحاها لكننا على
ثقه تامه اننا نسير في الطريق الصحيح
لبناء ثقافه الديمقراطيه والبدء في احترام
حقوق الانسان وهذا يعني اننا ربما نواجه
عقبات او اخفاقات لكننا نقوم بمعالجتها
ونستفيد من تجارب الدول الاخرى وكذلك
نتعلم من اخطائنا وممارساتنا الجيده لذا
فانني ارى انها عمليه بداناها ونسير في
الاتجاه الصحيح لتحقيقها ويمكن القول بان
الديمقراطيه واحترام حقوق الانسان في
البلاد يشهدان تطورا من يوم لاخر نحن بصدد
بناء مؤسسات للديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان
بحيث تصبح هذه الم جز لا يتجزا من ثقافتنا
هذا البروسيس هذا الطريق طويل جدا خاصه
الان هناك احتجاجات يعني لا علاقه لنا بما
تقوله هيومن رايس وتش او مؤسسات غربيه
احيانا ترتبط بمؤسسات سياسيه لكن هناك
احتجاجات وهناك عرقيات تعاني يعني هذا
البلد مكون من عرقيات واديان الاروم
يعانون من التهميش وهناك احتجاجات قائمه
انت كرئيس وزراء ماذا
تقدم لابناء شعبك ومعالجه هذا التفا
والتهميش الذي يعاني منه
البعض اعتقد انك كاعلام تدرك تماما ان
الاحتجاجات موجوده في كل مكان هذه الايام
ولكن ما اسباب هذه
الاحتجاجات تعلم ان تعداد اثيوبيا 100
مليون نسمه ورغم ذلك تمكنا خلال 15 عاما
من تحقيق الرقم المزدوج في النمو
الاقتصادي ونجحنا في انتشال غالبيه الشعب
من تحت خط الفقر ولكن لا يزال عندنا
22% من الشعب يقبعون تحت خط الفقر اي هناك
22 مليون شخص تحت خط الفقر فلا بد اذا ان
تسود هؤلاء حاله من السخط وان يكون لديهم
مطالب هائله من الحكومه وعلينا ان نتحرك
بطريقه سريعه هو ما نقوم به بالفعل لكن
علينا ان نستجيب لمشاكل هؤلاء الناس
وعلاوه على ذلك فان لدينا 4 مليون شاب ما
بين سن ال ع الى ال يحتاجون الى عمل
وعلينا توفير الوظائف لهم تفعل لتحقيق هذا
الامر لا يمكن لاي دوله ايجاد الوظائف ما
لم يكن لديها اقتصاد اكثر ديناميكيه يجب
ان يكون لديك اقتصاد ذو كثافه انتاجيه
عاليه على المستوى الزراعي والصناعي نعم
اننا نوفر حوالي مليوني وظيفه سنويا لكن
هذا العدد لا يزال غير كاف لذا فاننا نعمل
على تحويل اقتصادنا واجراء الاصلاحات
اللازمه للسماح بتوفير وظائف لهؤلاء
الشباب ومن هنا فاننا بحاجه الى
الاستثمارات من الخارج والداخل وهذا ما
جعلني اقوم بزياره للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده ودول
الخليج من اجل جذب المزيد من الاستثمارات
وزياده فرص العمل عفوا على المقاطعه هذه
الاستثمارات تحتاج الى وضع مستقر والى
حاله يعني مطمئنه هذه الاحتجاجات وحالات
التمرد قد تثير قلق
المستثمرين لقد ظلت اثيوبيا تنعم
بالاستقرار والامان على مدار السنوات ال5
الماضيه وما تشهده البلاد حاليا من احداث
ليس الا مرحله انتقاليه مؤقته وقد نجحنا
في احتوائها لقد اضحت اثيوبيا اليوم واحه
للامان والاستقرار
وقد هدات الاوضاع منذ ان اعلنا حاله
الطوارئ الشهر الماضي وسوف نعمل على توطيد
هذا الاستقرار فالجميع يعلم ان اثيوبيا
ظلت اكثر الدول استقرارا على مدار السنوات
الخش الماضيه وما يحدث حاليا هو حاله غضب
مؤقته ومحاوله من الشباب للتعبير للحكومه
عن حاله من عدم الرضا وهو ما نعمل على
معالجته وعندما ننتهي من حل مشكلاتهم
ستعود البلاد الى حاله الاستقرار المعهوده
والان عاد الاستقرار الى البلاد مره اخرى
وهذه العمليه الانتقاليه لا تؤثر على جذب
المستثمرين الى البلاد وهناك كثيرون ياتون
في الوقت الحالي الى اثيوبيا من اجل
الاستثمار لانهم يعلمون ان الحكومه مستقره
وقادره على احتواء
واحتواء حاله السخط بين افراد المجتمع وان
هذه الاحداث ليست الا تعبيرا من الشباب عن
احطهم
واستيائهم بعد الفاصل سيد رئيس الوزراء
ساسال عن علاقاتك الخارجيه الاقليميه
علاقاتكم المتوتره مع بعض الدول وايضا
اتهامات لمصر واريتريا بدعم حركات
الاحتجاج والتمرد هنا في اثيوبيا لكن قبل
ذلك على ذكر الاستثمارات الصين اكبر
مستثمر لديكم من من من هي قائمه
المستثمرين الاكبر في
اثيوبيا لدينا مستثمرون من بلدان عده على
راسها الصين والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
والهند وتركيا ولدينا ايضا مستثمرون من
دول غربيه مثل المملكه المتحده وكثير من
دول الاتحاد الاوروبي مثل هولندا التي
لديها انشطه كبيره في قطاع البستنه فنحن
لدينا مستثمرون من جميع انحاء العالم لكن
هم هم من ذكرتهم منذ
قليل ومعظم هؤلاء المستثمرين يقومون
بانشطه رائعه في اثيوبيا ولدينا ايضا
مستثمرون في قطاع الصناعات الخفيفه مثل
شركه بي في اتش الامريكيه وشركه اتش ان ام
السويديه فنحن لدينا مستثمرون رئيسيون من
اوروبا ومن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يقال ان اثيوبيا مدخل الصين الى افريقيا
واستثمارات بحجم 12 مليار دولار تقريبا
هذا الامر لا يوتر علاقتكم مع الولايات
المتحده وبينكم تحالف كبير معها وهناك
تنافس صيني امريكي على
افريقيا نعم الصين لديها استثمارات ضخمه
في بلادنا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه
كذلك فعوامل جذب الاستثمار لدينا لا تعتمد
على ايديولوجيات او توجهات سياسيه وانما
على المنافع التي سيجنيها المستثمرون من
اثيوبيا وذلك بالنسبه للجانب الصيني او
الامريكي والامر ذاته ينطبق على الدول
الغربيه بشكل عام ونحن نرى ان كلا
الجانبين لا يمكن الاستغناء عنه
فالصينية الى
الايديولوجيات والعمل على اساس المنفعه
المشتركه للمستثمرين والبلاد لدينا علاقات
استراتيجيه مع الصين وكذلك مع الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ومع اوروبا ولا نتبع
سياسه اقصاء لاي
طرف وطالما ان لدينا تفاهما واحتراما
متبادلا ومصالح مشتركه فما الذي يمنع من
الاستفاده من الاثمارات الصينيه
والامريكيه والدول الغربيه اثيوبيا دوله
قادره على التعاون مع جميع دول العالم في
جميع
المجالات اتوقف مع فاصل قصير سيد رئيس
الوزراء مشاهدينا الكرام بعده نتحدث في
علاقات اثيوبيا الاقليميه المتوتره
والاتهامات ايضا للنظام المصري واريتريا
بدعم الاحتجاجات والعلاقه ايضا رؤيه رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي للازمه في اليمن
والعلاقات العربيه ايضا مع دول الخليج
تفضلوا بالبقاء
[موسيقى]
معنا اهلا بكم من جديد مشاهدينا الكرام
المقابله من اثيوبيا في اديس بابا مع رئيس
الوزراء الاثيوبي السيد هايلي مريم دي
سالي مرحبا بك مجددا اتهمت بشكل صريح
ومباشر النظام المصري وارتريا
بدعم المعارضه الاثيوبيه ودعم جبهه الارم
والمحظوره ما هي ادلت على على على هذا
الدعم من الواضح والمعروف للجميع ان
اريتريا تعمل على زعزعه استقرار بلادنا
النظام الاريتري والقاده والسلطات
الارتريه يعملون على زعزعه استقرارنا
ويضعون ذلك على راس
اولوياتهم لكن هذا لن يتحقق لهم وهذا
التدخل غير المبرر في شؤوننا لن ينال من
اثيوبيا هناك نزاع حدو بيننا وبين اريتريا
لكن هذا امر شائع في افريقيا فحوالي 80%
الم من البلدان الافريقيه لم تحل نزاعاتها
الحدوديه بعد لكنها لم تلجا للقتال هناك
طريقه متحضره لحل هذا النزاع وهي ان نجلس
سويا على طاوله الحوار ونناقش القضايا
الخلافيه ونتوصل لحلول بشانها وقد عرضنا
ذلك على القياده الارتريه لكنهم اداروا
لنا ظهورهم ومع ذلك فان من مسؤوليتنا
معالجه هذهه القضايا مستقبلا لكنهم دائما
ما يكررون محاولاتهم الفاشله لزعزع
استقرارنا ومن جانبنا فسوف نستمر في اتخاذ
الاجراءات والتدابير المناسبه كلما قاموا
باي عمل لزعزع
امننا ما هي ما هي
الاجراءات لا حاجه الان لمثل هذه
الاجراءات نحن نعلم انهم يستهدفون
استقرارنا وقد اتخذنا الاجراءات المناسبه
على المستويين العسكري
والدبلوماسي وهذا سوف يستمر
مستقبلا اما فيما يخص مصر فلقد قلنا مرارا
وتكرارا ان هناك مؤسسات مصريه تاوي
وتستضيف وتمول جماعات ارهابيه اثيوبيه مثل
جبهه تحرير الارمو و اخرى مثل جماعه جبوت
سب وقد نفت السلطات المصريه صلتها بتلك
المؤسسات لكننا طالبنا الحكومه المصريه
باتخاذ الاجراءات الملائمه ازاء هذه
الجماعات التي تصول وتجول في القاهره
وتتلقى الدعم الماديه والمعنويه
والسياسيه وهذا معروف
للجميع فقط ادخل على يوتيوب وشاهد وسائل
الاعلام المصريه لتتاكد بنفسك من ان هذه
الجماعات الارهابيه تتلقى دعما من مؤسسات
مصريه فالامر اذا لا يحتاج الى معلومات
استخباراتيه لانه متوفر بالفعل على
الانترنت وقد بات غايه في الوضوح ومن هنا
فقد طالبنا السلطات المصريه بالتحقيق في
هذا الامر واتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه اذا
لم تكن لدي بالفعل صله بهذه الجماعات التي
تسعى من اجل زعزعه استقرار
اثيوبيا ماذا كان
ردهم ابلغوني حقق في الامر وطلبوا منا
معلومات
فاعطيناك في انتظار
ردهم لكن سيد رئيس الوزراء هذا عارض يعني
هذا نتيجه لسبب
لمشكله رئيسيه خاصه العلاقه التوتر مع مصر
تتعلق
ب مياه نهر النيل وسد النهضه وهذا الامر
الحساس والمصيري بالنسبه للمصريين بالتالي
لماذا لا تذهبون الى عمق المشكله انتم
ايضا يقال
انكم تؤثرون بشكل او باخر بهذه المشاريع
عبر سد النهضه الذي اكتمل الان تقريبا 80%
منه تؤثرون على على استقرار مصر وبالتالي
هي تقوم بهذا الامر كرده فعل على ما
تفعلونه ليس هذا هو
السبب ليس انشاء سد النهضه هو السبب في
هذه الازمه لاننا قمنا بجهود كبيره لبناء
جسور من الثقه بين الدول الثلاث المعنيه
وهناك اتفاق ثلاثي موقع بيننا في هذا
الشان وقد قررنا اعلان مبادئ سد النهضه
والذي وقع عليه قاده الدول الثلاث السودان
ومصر
واثيوبيا بهدف تحقيق مصلحه جميع
الاطراف لذا لا ارى ان الاستمرار في بناء
سد النهضه سبب في هذا التوتر لان السد قد
جرى تصميمه وسيتم بناؤه على نحو يضمن عدم
الاضرار باي من دول المصب مصر والسودان
واعتقد اننا قطعنا شوطا كبيرا لبناء الثقه
ولم يصلنا من السلطات المصريه كذلك ما
يفيد بان بناء السد يشكل سببا للتوتر
لاننا ماضون قدما في العمل ولدينا
مستشارون ايضا يقومون بدراسه اي اثار على
دول المصب وفي حاله اكتشاف اي اثار للسد
فسيتم اتخاذ الخطوات اللازمه لتفاديها في
المستق
القريب لذا لا يمكن ان يكون بناء السد هو
السبب في انعدام الثقه والتوترات
لقد انشئ السد بهدف توليد الطاقه
الهيدروليكيه والتي لا تستهلك المياه وقد
اتفقنا ايضا على طريقه اداره السد وتشغيله
وملئه بالماء خلال مراحل التشغيل
الاوليه فطالما ان هناك تعاونا بيننا على
المستويات الفنيه والسياسيه
والدبلوماسيه فما الداعي لتورط المؤسسات
المصريه في ذلك الامر هذا تصرف غير صائب
ان اثيوبيا ملتزمه بالعمل على تحقيق مصلحه
ومنفعه لجميع الاطراف وهذا ما يجب على
الجميع فهمه نحن ليس لدينا اي نوايا
للاضرار بمصالح الدول
الاخرى ممكن تطور الامور الى حرب مع فورجي
في اريتريا خاصه انكم محتقرين جدا ضده او
حول قضيه
النيل لدينا قناعه بان الحرب لا يمكن ان
تحل اي مشكله هناك حروب في كل مكان ولا
ينتج عنها سوى القتل
والتدمير لذا لا يمكنك ان تلج الى الحرب
الا اذا لم يكن لديك اي خيار اخر وبالنسبه
لنا لا يمكن ان تقودنا المشكلات الحاليه
الى حرب لان هناك فرصا كثيره لحلها من
خلال الحوار والقنوات
الدبلوماسيه ومن خلال بناء الثقه بين
الدول واذا كان هناك من يريد الحرب فهذا
خياره لكننا في هذه الحاله سنكون مستعدين
للدفاع عن انفسنا وليس لدينا اي مشكله في
خوض الحرب والتاريخ ششهد على كل من حاول
الدخول في حرب ضد اثيوبيا لكن كما قلت
فالحل لا يكمن في الحرب ولا اعتقد ان
القياده المصريه الحاليه ستلج الى خيار
الحرب لانها قياده مسؤوله هذه هي نظرتنا
للوضع الراهن وسوف نستمر في هذا الطريق
متمسكين بمواقف المستنده الى مبدا حل جميع
الخلافات عن طريق
الحوار تريدون علاقه مميزه مع العرب
وتعرفون حجم الاحتقان من اسرائيل دوله
الاحتلال التي تحتل فلسطين لديكم علاقات
تاريخيه مؤخرا استقبلت نتنياهو استقبال
كبير
ودعمتهم يعني طلبه بوجود اسرائيل كمراقب
في الاتحاد
الافريقي اسرائيل تؤثر حتى على مصر بشكل
او باخر عبر علاقاتها مع اثيوبيا الذي
فوجئت به سيد رئيس الوزراء حجم التبادل
التجاري ليس كبيرا ب بين اثيوبيا واسرائيل
يعني لدينا انطباعات ذهنيه
ربما ماذا تريدون من اسرائيل ومن العلاقه
معها وهي دوله
احتلال مستفزه في المنطقه
كلها دعني اقول لك ان اثيوبيا لا تبني
علاقاتها مع الدول استنادا الى اراء دول
اخرى وانما بالنظر الى ما يحقق مصالحنا
الوطنيه ويمكننا ان نكون اصدقاء لاسرائيل
ولدول العربيه في نفس الوقت لكن هنا سيد
الرئيس بالتاكيد بالتاكيد لا تبنون
علاقاتكم على مصالح العرب لكن هناك مبادئ
ايضا هذه ال دوله
محتله منتهكه لحقوق الانسان ارتكبت ابشع
جرائم في التاريخ الحديث وانتم الاثيوبي
شعب مسالم تاريخكم يعني لا يحتاج لهذه
العلاقه اعتقد ان علينا التاكيد على ان
مواقف اثيوبيا تستند دائما الى
المبادئ واذا اعتدت دوله ما على اخرى
وعرضت حياه الاخرين للخطر فلا يمكن ان
ننحاز الى اي طرف والعلاقه بين اسرائيل
وفلسطين يجب ان تكون قائمه على حل
الدولتين الشعب الفلسطيني يستحق ان تكون
له دولته المستقله
وكذلك الاسرائيليون يجب ان يشعروا بالامن
والامان هذا امر ضروري لذا فان حل
الدولتين امر ضروري بالنسبه لهما من اجل
ضمان اقامه علاقه جوار جيده بين
الطرفي لماذا انا اسف على المقاطعه لماذا
تريدونها مراقب في الاتحاد
الافريقي اسرائيل ت ع بعلاقات صداقه مع
الكثير من الدول
الافريقيه ولا يعني منح اسرائيل صفه
المراقب لا يعني عدم وجود اي خلافات ربما
يكون هناك خلافات لكن من الممكن حلها من
خلال المشاركه واستبعاد فرضيه استحاله
الحلول وما نريد تحقيقه في النهايه هو
التوصل الى حلول تضمن التعايش بين الدول
وتضمن تحقيق المصالح والثقه المشتركه اننا
نؤمن باهميه المشاركه وعدم استبعاد اي طرف
كوسيله لحل الخلافات ولذا نريد ان تكون
اسرائيل جزءا منا وكذلك نريد ان تكون
فلسطين جزءا منا حتى يمكننا حل المشكلات
بين الطرفين انني ارى ان الخلافات يمكن
تجاوزها من خلال الحوار فقط لا من خلال
الحرب او العدوان على ذكر الاتحاد
وافريقيا الملك المغرب ايضا زار اثيوبيا
وحظي بدعم منكم في مساله عوده العضويه ما
موقفكم من من المغرب ومن قضيته ومن مطلبه
اليوم ومن نشاط ايضا الملك محمد السادس
النشاط الافريقي اللافت في الفترات
الاخيره اعتقد ان المغرب تاخر كثيرا وكان
عليه ان يتحرك منذ زمن
طويل لانه دوله افريقيه وينتمي الى القاره
الافريقيه لديه كل الحق في ان يكون جزءا
من الاتحاد
الافريقي وعندما يعود المغرب الى الاتحاد
الافريقي هذه المنظمه التي اسستها الدول
الافريقيه لخدمه مصالحها فانه يستعيد بذلك
وضعه الطبيعي في القاره
الافريقيه وانا شخصيا سعيد برجوع المغرب
الى مكانته الطبيعيه كعضو مؤسس للاتحاد
الافريقي يجب ان يكون المغرب جزءا من
الاتحاد الافريقي واننا سعيدون جدا بهذا
القرار بعدها زرت السعوديه بعد زياره
الملك الى ادي سباب هل تمت ارتباط بال
الامرين
لا كانت مصادفه محضه زياره السعوديه جاءت
ضمن برنامج محدد سلفا لتقييم بعض
الاتفاقات الموقعه مع المملكه منذ عام مضى
وكذلك لتعزيز الاتفاقات القائمه والاتفاق
الذي تم التوصل اليه بين السعوديه
واثيوبيا كانت الزياره تهدف الى معالجه
بعض القضايا المتعلقه بملف القرن الافريقي
وهو ملف حساس جدا في ظل الانتخابات
الحاليه في الصومال وكذلك هناك بعض
المشكلات المتعلقه بجنوب السودان واثيوبيا
هي المسؤوله عن تهدئه الاوضاع في هذه
المنطقه ونتطلع الى الحصول على دعم دول
الخليج في هذا الشان لا سما المملكه
العربيه السعوديه باعتبارها الدوله الاكبر
في المنطقه وقد اطلقنا اتفاقات لتشجيع
وحمايه الاستثمار
والتي وقعت في وقت سابق ونتطلع الى مجيء
اعداد كبيره من السعوديين للاستثمار في
اثيوبيا وكذلك للسياحه فكما اشرت اثيوبيا
هي موطن الجاشي وهي مكان جدير
بالزياره نريد النجاشي جديد هنا في
اثيوبيا يبدو ان قضايا وازمات العرب كثيره
اشعر ان التاريخ عامل مهم جدا وسوف نركز
على تاريخنا لتعريف الناس بما كان يدور في
هذا البلد بوصفه مكانا مقدسا ماذا عن
اليمن السعوديه طبعا تقود التحالف في حرب
اليمن وانتم بالنسبه يعني انتم اليمن ربما
اكثر دوله عربيه لها علاقه تاريخيه
باثيوبيا ما هي نظرتكم لما يجري في اليمن
ولحل في
اليمن
دعني اعبر عن تقديري لما يقوم به التحالف
العربي لاستعاده الامن والاستقرار في
اليمن من المهم ان يتم حل هذه الازمه
باسرع وقت ممكن من خلال الحوار
والتفاوض لان العمل العسكري لا يساهم في
ايجاد اي حلول ومن جانبنا فاننا نحث كافه
الاطراف على حل الازمه من خلال
المفاوضات
واثيوبيا مستعده للتعاون مع الجميع في هذا
الشان لاننا اصدقاء للجميع وكما اشرت فان
لدينا علاقات تاريخيه واصول مشتركه مع
اليمن وعلي عبد الله صالح
ايضا نعم مع علي عبد الله صالح عندما كان
في الحكم لقد عرضنا المساعده في عمليه
السلام هناك لان هذا مهم جدا بالنسبه لنا
فاضطراب في اليمن تلقي بظلالها على
المملكه السعوديه وكذلك على
اثيوبيا وهذا ينعكس سلبا على شريط البحر
الاحمر بالكامل لذا يجب العمل على تهدئه
الاوضاع في اليمن باسرع وقت ممكن والقاده
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ودول التحالف
يتحلون بالمسؤوليه وبالتالي فهم قادرون
على تهدئه الوضع هناك وهم يسيرون بالفعل
في الاتجاه الصحيح وهذا سيساعدنا على
المضيه قدما سيد رئيس الوزراء عاده الملف
الاثيوبي بالنسبه للسعوديه او دول الخليج
حساس لانه عاده عبر
مصر تكون العلاقه او او او تكون هناك خشيه
حتى من تطوير العلاقه هل يبدو انه جفاء في
في العلاقات السعوديه المصريه ربما اسهم
في هذا التحرك باتجاه اثيوبيا بينكم وبين
السعوديه لا يمكن بناء المصالح على سوء
التفاهم وانعدام الثقه بين الدول وانما
يتحقق ذلك من خلال التفاهم والثقه
والتعاون بين الدول بعضها البعض واننا
دائما نرى ان قوه مصر افضل خيار بالنسبه
لنا فكلما كانت مصر قويه كانت اثيوبيا
قويه والعكس صحيح وكلما كانت السعوديه
كانت اثيوبيا قويه وكذلك الحال بالنسبه
لكل دول الخليج نحتاج اليها دائما قويه
ومزدهر وشعوبها تنعم بحياه افضل وبالتالي
فان العلاقات بيننا يجب ان تقوم على
المصلحه المشتركه ولسنا ممن يحبون استغلال
سوء التفاهم القائم بين الدول فما نتوق
اليه هو تحقيق الامن والاستقرار الدائمين
في منطقه القرن الافريقي ومنطقه الخليج
وشريط البحر الاحمر هذه هي المصلحه
الحقيقيه بالنسبه لنا اثيوبيا تتطلع للمضي
قدما في الرقم المزدوج في النمو الذي تحقق
على مدار ال 15 عاما الماضيه وهذا لن
يتحقق من دون الامن والاستقرار لذا فنحن
نعمل على تحقيق الامن والاستقرار لدول
الجوار الصومال وجنوب السودان وكذلك ندعم
الاستقرار في اليمن لاننا ببساطه نستفيد
من استقرار هذه الدول سيد رئيس الوزراء
قضيه الموانع حقيقه ثمت امر لافت وهو
استثمارات الدوليه في الموانئ البعض
يسميها حرب موانئ الامارات مثلا تستثمر في
مينائين في في عصب وفي بربره في
صوماليلاند تركيا في مقديش والصين في
جيبوتي واثيوبيا معزوله عن عن المياه عن
البحر بعد طبعا استقلال اريتريا كيف
تنظرون لهذه المساله لا تشكل قلقا خطرا
بالنسبه بالنسبه
لبلادكم لدينا علاقات متميزه جدا مع جميع
جيراننا باستثناء
اريتريا لدينا علاقات جيده مع الصومال ومع
صومالي لاند كادار مستقله في الوقت الحالي
الى ان تحصل على استقلالها كدوله لدينا
اذا علاقات تعاون وجوار متميزه مع الصومال
ومع صومالي لاند ولدينا كذلك علاقه جيده
مع السودان ونستخدم ميناء السودان ولدينا
علاقات ممتازه مع جيبوتي ونستخدم ميناء
جيبوتي وكذلك ايضا نستخدم ميناء بربره
ونخطط مستقبلا لاستخدام ميناء مومباسا
نظرا لعلاقتنا الجيده مع كينيا
وبالتالي فنحن نثمن جميع علاقاتنا بدول
الجوار وليس لدينا اي مشكله في حضور اي
مستثمر للعمل في هذه الموانئ طالما ان هذا
لا يشكل تهديدا لمصالحنا ومننا
القومي وحتى الان لم يواجه المستثمرون في
المنطقه اي
مشكله هناك حالات عدائيه في كل مكان لكن
هذا لا يعني ان ندخل في مواجهات مع
اصدقائنا
وشركائنا ولهذا فاننا نعمل جاهدين على
تعزيز علاقاتنا الاستراتيجيه بجيران
والسير وفق اجنده مشتركه لتحقيق الامن
والاستقرار والرخاء لشعوبنا ولا نشعر باي
تهديد او خطر من جيراننا حتى مع اريتريا
فاننا نرى ان التوتر فيما بيننا امر عارض
سببه السذاجه التي تتسم بها القياده
الارتريه وهذه الحاله لا يمكن ان تستمر
طويلا تعملون على تغيير النظام في
اريتريا تغيير نظام الحكم شان يخص الشعب
الاريتري وليس لاثيوبيا اي دخل فيه اذا
اراد الشعب ذلك فهذا ليس بالامر العسير
اما من حيث المبدا فاننا لا نتدخل في
الشان الداخلي للدول الاخرى
الشعب الاريتري هو المسؤول عن تغيير نظام
الحكم اما نحن فلا لكن ما نؤمن به هو ان
هذه المشكله ستحل يوما ما قريبا سيد رئيس
الوزراء اود ان اسالك عن افريقيا هذه
القاره الرائعه وال
المهمشه في فترات طويله والطامح ايضا
القاره الشابه والقاره التي تم يعني
استغلال مق مراتها طوال قرون قبل الغرب
واحتلالها بشكل كبير وتم ايضا تنميط حتى
حتى بالاسم القاره السوداء محاوله
يعني محاوله تنميط بشكل سلبي حتى اليوم
عندكم الاتحاد الافريقي
عندكم عده دول ديمقراطيه دول
متقدمه احلام احلام بعمله موحده بتقارب
اكبر هل يبدو انه هذا الامر قريب وواقعي
ام انه ما زالت افريقيا تغرق في الجهل
والفقر والامراض
والمجاعات القاره الافريقيه باكملها تشهد
نهضه ملحوظه فلو نظرنا الى الع سنه
الماضيه سيتبين لنا ان الدول الافريقيه قد
شهدت تطورات كبيره خاصه خلال العشر سنوات
الاخيره هناك الكثير من البلدان الافريقيه
التي شهدت ارتفاعا في معدلا النمو على عكس
اتجاه النمو المنخفض للاقتصاد العالمي
وهذا يوضح ان افريقيا في صعود ملحوظ وانها
باتت وجهه للاستثمارات الاجنبيه المباشره
بطريقه او باخرى كما ان افريقيا قاره
رائعه والكثيرون يرغبون في زيارتها اعتقد
ان ما نحتاجه في افريقيا هو تهدئه الاوضاع
لدينا خطه لاسكات الاسلحه في افريقيا حتى
تستفيد الشعوب الافريقيه من الازدهار الذي
يشهده العالم نتطلع الى تحقيق التكامل في
قاره افريقيا ولدينا خطه لتحقيق ذلك بحلول
عام
2063 وهناك ايضا خطه عشريه لتكامل القاره
وهذه اجنده ستنفذ على مدار 50 عاما هناك
رؤيه يجب العمل على تحقيقها وهي مهمه شاقه
انظر الى الاتحاد الاوروبي بعد اندماج دام
لسنوات بدات بعض الدول في مغادرته والبعض
الاخر يحاول سلوك نفس المسلك فهذه ليست
بالمهمه الس سهله لكن الافارقه قد التزموا
بتحقيق الاندماج على المستوى السياسي في
مرحله سابقه والان من الاهميه بمكان تحقيق
الاندماج على المستوى الاقتصادي وهو ما
نسعى اليه سيد رئيس الوزراء حينما يعني
توليت منصب رئاسه الوزراء ذكرت بدايه
الحلقه قيل في التقارير الدوليه انه الرجل
لن يبقى فتره طويله فاجات الجميع اربعه
اعوام الان انتخبت ايضا لاربعه اعوام اخرى
هل ستبقى طويلا في رئاسه الوزراء مثلما
كان ميل الزيناوي اكثر من 21 سنه
[موسيقى]
تقريبا اولا اوود ان اعبر عن سعادتي
بالتقدم الذي نعيشه في البلاد
والحقيقه ان قياده دوله بمثل هذه
الحال تمثل فرصه بالنسبه لي
لكنها في الوقت ذاته مسؤوليه ثقيله
جدا ومن وجهه نظري اذا كان عملي في الخدمه
العامه ضروريا بالنسبه للشعب
الاثيوبي فسوف امضي حياتي كلها في القيام
بواجبي سواء من خلال منصبي الحالي ام من
خلال اي منصب اخر يمكن ان
اتقلد لذا لا ينتاب القلق حيال المده التي
سامضي في الحكم كل ما يهمني هو رؤيه هذا
البلد يمضي الى الامام وان ننجح في القضاء
على
الفقر هذه اولويه ملحه لاننا نعاني من فقر
متقع على الرغم من اننا قطعنا شوطا كبيرا
في تحسين هذا
الوضع لكن ما يزال امامنا الكثير للقيام
به
فالمصيف
قلقي فيمكن لشخص اخر ان ياتي مكاني ويكمل
مسيره التقدم لكن طالما ان الفرصه متاحه
لي فسوف استمر في القيام
بمسؤوليتي ازاء هذا البلد وبناء علاقات
متينه مع جيراننا ومع الدول الافريقيه
بشكل عام وايضا مع دول الخليج فما اتطلع
اليه هو بناء علاقات قويه بين اثيوبيا
ودول الخليج وبصفتك صحفيا في الجزيره ومن
اصول سعوديه اود ان اخبرك باننا نتطلع
لبناء علاقات ناضجه ومتينه معها واؤكد على
اننا سنستمر في تعزيز وتعميق علاقاتنا مع
كافه دول الخليج وشريط البحر
الاحمر وقاره
افريقيا انا قادم من تلك المنطقه وكما
اؤكد واعيد واؤكد انني يعني لمست هنا شيء
حقيقه مختلف يبدو انه هذا الشعور فعلا
العلاقه التاريخيه اتمنى ان تكون العلاقه
ايضا اكبر بين بين اثيوبيا وبين بلداننا
العربيه ومنطقه الخليج على وجه التحديد
اشكرك سييد رئيس الوزراء شكرا جزيلا على
وقتك ولقاك ان شاء الله قريبا شكرا جزيلا
لك شكرا جزيلا على الاستضافه وكما انبك
هذا الشعور في اثيوبيا فسوف ينتاب الكثير
من مواطن الخليج عند زيارتهم لاثيوبيا ومن
هنا فانني ادعوهم لزياره هذا البلد الرائع
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
الكرام احييكم من اديس بابا في هذا اللقاء
الذي اجرينا مع رئيس الوزراء في اثيوبيا
سيد حيلي مريم دي سال شكرا لكم نلقاكم ان
شاء الله في الحلقه القادمه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ن